[Music]
we're looking into disappearances
some recent others dating back several
years
the pattern is disturbing
i transferred from missing persons harry
hall
we studied your cases at the academy
they did back that far
yeah you're up there with the legends i
can't keep covering for you
it doesn't matter who you are tell me
i think it's the falling snow that sets
the killer off
then who does he leave the snowman for
building snowmen cutting things up into
little pieces that's what a child does
to establish order
a call just came in there's another
missing woman
we got the missing person's call who's
missing sylvia otterson i'm sylvia
artisan
why would someone report you missing
he reported her missing before he killed
her
i don't want a word of this to be leaked
[Music]
it was a suicide and a story you sure he
was alone
where's katrine
i received this it's personal
[Music]
he was watching us the whole time he's
playing games
you could save them
give you all the clues and everything
[Music]
you